the population is rising the climate is
in a
big change and you have to do something
about that if you look in the medical
side and you look about diabetes you
look about about uh
people are more
i would say gaining weight
uh in a
in a good american
phrase i would say
so this is a huge problems of the world
and the food
industry
that is now
right in the in this you know starting
the j curve i would say
um
is trying to deal with that
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i'm
going to talk to hanan schneider the ceo
of millennium food tech he's an
entrepreneur ceo and experienced
investor in startup companies ceo and
co-founder of millennium food tech a
traded tassie venture capital fund
before establishing millennium he
initiated established and managed the
food tech incubator in kiriyachimona
israel khan was the entrepreneur of
indimed and managed startup companies
such as beta02 nittiloop and others from
the initiation to market penetration
as ceo of these companies he raised
significant amounts from vc funds and
strategic partners in israel and abroad
and i'm schneider welcome to 20 minute
leaders good to have you here
thank you very much it's great to
be here as well
thank you for joining me today um i love
talking about different industries and
today i get to talk about food tech and
i get to talk about your journey today
venture capitalists previously
entrepreneur and today you know
investing in and supporting food tech
entrepreneurs in the israeli ecosystem
and some incredible companies some of
which i also had on the show savory and
you also invested in in in
in other companies that have made big
headlines over the last few weeks and
months which is very very exciting and
and you know looking over the website
one of the immediate things that i that
i saw is sort of the messaging on on you
know what is food tech and how is it
emerging and the you know the the
dissonance between the capital that is
needed for it versus how much there is
versus the how critical it is for the
future of our world and and what's
happening here so i'm excited to touch
on all these aspects with you but before
we do that tell me a little bit about
yourself about your journey who you are
okay so uh
so it's interesting because i'm all the
time dancing between operational
positions and investor positions so i
started with the in the capital markets
in the lim capital market and discount
capital markets and when i headed the
investment arm of different capital
markets and sat at the board of
directors of several companies i
understood that it's great to sit on the
board of directors
but for me to tell the ceo what to do or
what i think he has to do
you know it has to be a with merits so
uh so i moved and i found
uh a company that i established together
with josie gross is a is a entrepreneur
uh in the medical side and we establish
better two technologies and then i
started my journey as a ceo with
operational heavy approach and
background you know managing guarantee
and activities raising funds from
israeli and u.s based venture
capitalists did deals with
big american companies such as abyamed
and boston scientific abbot etc
and then you know and and then i moved
to be a venture capitalist at agate and
then moved back
to manage knitty loop where i did a
massive or big
clinical trials
fda approvals etc and then you know four
years ago
when i thought of about what i want to
do next
i managed to uh be with uh mr chuck bear
jack bear is the
owner and the ceo of temple industries
and you know he told me that a new
tender is coming
for the
putec incubators up in the north of
israel
so
he told me you know i don't know about
startup companies and how to uh help
them but i know that i want to be in
foodtech and bradford tech
and i said i know a lot about managing
startups and helping them to grow but i
don't know a lot about foodtech but i
knew that footage is going to change the
world
and then we we merged basically and and
i worked with the temple group and then
nuva came and finished stale in our
crowd and we won the tender
and established fresh start incubator uh
did the first deals and then i moved
uh to a
with a group of of uh capital markets
guys and we co-founded millennium
foodtech where i'm now the ceo
we already raised about 40 million
dollars
and we invest in food the companies
but
uh in their latest stage and i would
tell you in a minute what is latest
stage for us
so
i'm about four years in this food tech
and this is really changing the world
and and it's amazing and when we talked
in the medical side uh about half a
billion dollar companies billion dollar
companies when you're talking about food
and beverages
it's trillion dollars come a market
share it's it's it's amazing and it's
affecting
every one of us not on the six but also
on the healthier guys
so
just give you if if that's okay with you
i can continue to talk 100 percent
though go ahead so if if that's okay
with you i will give you the framework
of what we see in the israeli ecosystem
in the future so
about seven seven to eight years ago
we saw the big companies awakening
and starting to try to find technologies
in the
uh in the places of
sugar reduction salt reduction etc
um protein alternative protein and then
we saw migration of scientists in israel
that got grants
from outside from outside of israel of
course
to towards
new technologies to fruitex so then came
the science so we saw scientists start
to research
on this kind of areas and then we have
the
technology level so about four and a
half five years ago the first incubator
in israel the kitchen hub
started together with the visionary
browse group headed by ofra you know
really visionary nobody knew about what
is foodtech everybody was what is futec
who is the investor you know i talked
with amir
who is the vp bizdev
four years ago he told me that he has a
lot of companies a lot of technologies
but
nobody investing in that
and they have a really rough time back
then
but now
we saw that a lot of these companies
about 300 companies
moved from the science the technology
into the what i called
a
poc level or a company that is
for the company level so the past
technology now there is a company
there is a poc
they maybe they have done some pilots
and now they need money for scale up
regulation pilots
selling etc etc and this is exactly
where i want to be this is exactly how
we built our team and this is what is
needed in israel because there is almost
no dedicated fund in foottech in israel
which is something that we can explore
but
it's it's very interesting that there is
at least you know there is fresh start
incubator there is the kitchen trendline
is doing argan footage and there are
others and in in the innovation lab with
iff innovation lab etc
but there is no
the
upper layer i would say or the next
in-line
investment
vehicle
there is none almost nothing until we
came
so i think it's an interesting question
and you're posing the question of you
know whether this is a you know a
traditional evolutionary
process that now we they were starting
with incubators and now we're going to
level up and and perhaps through this
hypothesis that in the next few years we
will see some these some dedicated vcs
emerging like the investment group that
that you're running today take me
a little bit towards this idea of food
tech in general because this is a new
concept that um that that is being
spoken more and more about you know i
don't i don't remember 10 15 years ago
really people working on these things or
or being a mainstream for a young
entrepreneur to go and salmon i'm going
to go into food tech
so what what has been happening over the
last few years and and how do you and
you know what what is it like even to
build a company in the foodtech industry
versus other traditional industries that
we know about
so so you're absolutely right
so we didn't used to see anything in
foottech and on top of that
entrepreneurs and ceos of these
companies
came from another places so if you look
at the
of the
a lot of the ceos are coming from the
medical side because this is the most
closer
field i would say to the food deck but
the big companies and i think if you
look at what is going on you see the
glasgow cropped 2 206 um and climate
conference which is you know everybody
is saying
and they are right that
the population is rising the climate is
in a
big change and you have to do something
about that if you look in the medical
side and you look about diabetes you
look about about
uh
people are more
i would say gaining weight
in a
in a good american
phrase i would say
so this is a huge problems of the world
and the food
industry
that is now
right in the in this you know starting
the j curve i would say
um
is trying to deal with that and the big
companies and the issue here is the big
companies the nestled and on
um
um of the world and also in israel if
you look about nueva strauss nestle
awesome etc unilever are under
understand that
declare that they are going to do
something in these areas and
invest in that or doing pilot on that
field so this drive the business so this
for example if you look at the at the
technion at the technical they used to
have
a faculty
with the title of biotechnology and
and food engineering where in the
biotech
there were
nine
in the rate of nine
uh researchers and in the food
uh engineering was one
old guy that used to teach about what is
technology and wow and today and today
after that we saw a huge migration that
now 60 more than 60 percent in this
faculty is dedicated to foodtech
and i will give you another story just
to
illustrate that
so let's say that eight years ago the
ceo of awesome nestle
wanted to have a new snack a new beastly
in the market so we went to do a market
survey and everybody told him we want a
beastly with a taste of shawarma okay so
we went back to his labs with a lab
technician and told them i want busy
shawarma they said thank you very much
okay
and now what are the tools that they
used
salt
sugar brothering from animals
um
taste
and colorants
from around
synthetics most of them
and today all the tools
have vanished so because of the red if
you know the red
reform where you have to
pinpoint and to give a sticker on the
product that you have
high sugar high fat etc
so today
the
food engineers
cannot use anything so they cannot use
salt they cannot use sugar more sugar
they are changing their ways of how to
get colorant taste etc because some of
them considered to be
cancers
and and so a protein nobody wants
to kill animals to get proteins nobody
wants gluten anymore
and i can tell you that in a lot of
these companies
when they are looking on the next three
years they are saying i don't want this
and this in my production line
and this drive the industry
towards that
now if you're looking at the
entrepreneurial perspective
and more on the leadership front so so
there's so
fascinating market shifts from the
entrepreneur's perspective
what is it like for the entrepreneur to
be going through the perhaps early or
growth stages of a futa company versus
some of the more mainstream industries
that we know about
so it's a very good uh
observation i would say because
when we look on the foottech
entrepreneurs most of them weren't
cos before so today if you look at this
at the cyber and that communication
startups you see a lot of second timers
people that already built
startups maybe maybe didn't succeed with
with them but they know what is the
startup in the foottech area a lot of
this entrepreneur doesn't know
what is to be a ceo of a startup company
what is to raise money what is to build
the company etc etc and this is
something that we as millennium
are
keen to help them and mentor them in
order to do such kind of development
meaning personal development in order to
be a ceo of a successful startup company
right and this is something that we put
a lot of efforts on that
in the other way we see ceos coming from
other industries that already have done
something mainly from the medical side
so uh they understand what is regulation
what is scale up what is you know uh do
some clinical trials if needed etc etc
and then you can get uh some other
um i would say expertise and knowledge
from and how to manage
data but in many ways we see
uh
that the entrepreneur
you have to mentor them you have to help
them you they don't understand what is a
term sheet what are they the terms in
the television what is fully diluted
what is preference rights etc and this
is
something that you know
have to be
uh uh i have to
teach them in many ways
uh just one thing
in many ways we take
uh we take managers from the a big
um
uh big
com the big companies in israel such as
new van nestle etc
and then also they don't know what is to
be a starter beast but this is the other
way around that understand the market
they understand what you need to do they
understand sales and marketing but they
don't understand
what it to be what is it to build the
startup how to raise money how to get uh
the iaa
grants and other uh
funding etc etc and this is also
something that that the vcs the
incubators as a doing
with these companies
i think that makes a lot of sense now
when you do a due diligence process on
a company in the food tech sector do you
think or do you observe that your is it
a similar process to you know
traditional tech company that is perhaps
doing software as a service or ai or
cyber how is your diligence process
similar or different
so basically
it is very similar
plus but but you have to take into
account the special parameters that are
a
there for the foot tech startups such as
regulation
this
field it's heavily regulated and if you
don't don't understand the regulation
there is something that you
this is it's fundamental
uh something that you that you will fail
with that no but but in other cases it's
very similar
um
and i wanted to
to add on that
that
when you uh look at this
a company's
uni
it's it's very easy to understand the
size of the market so the size of the
market here
is huge
you you cannot be overwhelmed
with this kind of big market you have to
find
the niche
that you are going to uh
that you are going to how you are going
to penetrate what is your the go-to
market strategy this is something that
is very very
important in the due diligence process
and
this is why
one of our board members neely tour
uh who held
if a
managerial positions in awesome nestle
and with nestle
is very good with and help these
companies to have a strategy for go to
market and to understand what is the go
to market is coming from the marketing
and managerial positions so this is how
we built our team and and and directors
to help the companies
take them from the technology okay i i
have a poc i have a a product now what
i'm going to do with it this is a huge
something that you need to help these
companies uh uh to to take them to the
next level
very very very cool and
i really want to thank you for coming
here i think we can continue this
conversation for much much longer
but but it was but it was amazing to get
a glimpse of it of your experience in
the food tag sector both in the israel
ecosystem but in general and i have one
last question for you and if i were to
ask any of your entrepreneurs or anybody
around you how would they describe hanan
in a few words
what would be a few words that would
come to their mind
i think very involved
very keen to help us
and uh
a good person to be to partner with
so this is a lot
i'll take it
you know you can ask them i i
might just do that and i and i
appreciate it i really appreciate this
time it was fantastic and i and i
learned a lot so thank you and stay safe
and stay healthy and best of luck with
your current portfolio with the upcoming
portfolio and for for making a positive
impact on on our israeli industry but
also in in the way that you know humans
are going to you know get food in in the
coming years and i think it's going to
be really exciting
exactly thank you very very much mike
mikhail for the this talk thank you